moving on seven-time nascar champion
that would be jimmy johnson
is hoping to be a driver for change you
could say both on and off the racetrack
johnson is a longtime friend and
supporter of bubba wallace we love him
too
the only black driver in nascar's top
tier in june what looked like a noose
later found to be a door pool
door pool rather was found in wallace's
garage bay at talladega super speedway
bubba wallace was featured in the
november issue of oh the oprah magazine
and jimmy johnson
writes the tribute he says this i hope
that bubba's bravery can lead all of us
in racing
to think about ways to make it more
inclusive today
johnson is being honored for his own
inclusion efforts
with a nascar drive for a diversity
award and right now we are so happy to
say
hi jimmy johnson it's so good to see you
hello
may i say that when you agreed to be on
the show well my other job is at oprah
magazine and when you agreed to
write the tribute we were doing the hula
people started applauding and said jimmy
said yes jimmy said yes we were so
excited
but you share in that writing you said
that you and bob have been friends for a
very long time close to 15 years
but you had never had a discussion with
him about the challenges of being the
only black
driver in nascar and once you two
started talking about it was very
revealing to you why did you start
talking
and what did you learn how did it affect
you
well really with george floyd's passing
i
bob and i just started talking about
that topic and
i i realized in the conversation that
bubba today deals with things that i've
never dealt with
still and i've known him for so many
years
and we've always talked racing and kind
of current life events
but we've never gone there and then once
we went there
it inspired me to talk to many other
friends of mine in the black community
hispanic community
far and wide and it was much more
revealing than
than i was aware of so i i put that on
myself
and spent a lot of time learning and
listening and certainly grew a lot in
these last
few months and understanding the big
picture as many americans have and
people around the world for that matter
jimmy i love the story that you wrote
about about how bubba was stopped by
police
and how bubble how bubba handled it and
now you said
how you would have handled it
yeah to to totally different uh
scenarios and that was an example of
just how different
my my experience has been versus his
yeah because you said i don't know if i
would have held my tongue
there's a point is the point i'm making
because i think it's
i think it's really refreshing for you
to say something like that to say
i never really thought about anything
like that and i wouldn't have accepted
that kind of behave the way he was
treated
because the cop specifically said to him
exactly can you afford this car that was
a question they said to him
yeah and i'm confident that's not a
question that i would would
receive being pulled over and cited and
now nascar has banned the confederate
flags you have a lot to say about that
because some of them are still flying
um at nascar what do you think when you
see that what do you think people need
to know and understand
that it's hurtful and i i do
respect the argument that everybody has
a right
for freedom of speech and expression but
you're welcome to do that on your
private property when
you're at a sporting event or a public
facility inclusion should be the top
priority
and to fly a flag that is hurtful and
painful for many
is just not acceptable and i'm proud of
nascar and the efforts they've made this
year to really remove the flag from the
tracks
and bubba is a huge part of why that all
happened
jimmy in the op-ed you also write how
you were disgusted
when you first heard about the news the
fbi and nascar later said it was a
garage door pull but i'm
i'm wondering what your conversations
bubba with bubba
were like when he was going through that
that news came out um and i guess maybe
saturday evening
prior to our race and i had already gone
to sleep
and woke up to the news and as soon as i
read it i texted bubba that i wanted to
stand with him during the national
anthem
uh just as a friend just i wanted to be
there for him i couldn't believe what i
was
was reading that morning and then word
traveled that i was
intending to stand with him and other
drivers asked if
if it was okay if they were involved i'm
like well of course
absolutely and within a few hours team
members
team managers everybody wanted to figure
out how to show their support
and other drivers came up with great
ideas and that's kind of how we evolved
from me standing with him at the
national for the national anthem
to all the drivers pushing his car down
pit road and the entire garage area
falling out behind bubba to show support
it was a stunning moment amazing that
was a stunning moment jimmy do you think
michael jordan recently became the first
black owner uh nascar's first black
principal owner
do you think that's going to make a
difference
without a doubt i mean it's michael
jordan and his voice in sports
his voice outside of sports is just so
massive
and i'm really happy for michael i've
known him for a lot of years
and i know his upbringing here in the
north carolina area
and being close to nascar and it being a
sport he and his family would attend and
watch together
so i'm happy he's involved for many
reasons and i think the pairing with
with bubba wallace and then even denny
hamlin
and the assets i like what you said
jimmy well number one he's michael
jordan let's just start with that good
things happen when it's michael jody
so do you ever see yourself racing with
team jordan because bubba's now going to
be his first driver
do you see yourself possibly racing with
them
that would be very cool i would be open
to it i'm kind of in transition right
now
but uh my focus is on indycar here in
the years to come
okay but i don't think people would be
mad to see you and bubba together with
michael jordan
i like that picture i would take the
call and talk about it for sure
all right jimmy johnson thank you thank
you thank you for joining us this
morning getting up early and writing
that piece
in the magazine we were very very
excited about it we really appreciate it